that's why play-doh me with a huge
jagoff class dismissed
wait but you didn't give us any homework
Dave can I talk to you for a second in
private look if this is about the dick
pics I mean you can't just say hey
that's your dude that's not it what do
you mean by dick pics my friend
his name's dick and he's short and okay
we'll listen Dave I understand that
you're quite a competitor with women you
mean a player yes a player now I'm
getting into the game and uh I needed
some advice cuz I'm going out with a
very high temperature woman tonight you
mean hot woman yes hot woman studies
professor yes I don't think I can help
you well then maybe I'll do a little
investigation into those dingdong
photographs
I'll help good
yeah thank you okay now what happens
when a woman find professor rich expert
in science these are my devoted students
together with the aid of harmless drugs
we explore Sciences greatest
hypothetical questions
you
e equals M c-squared discovered by
Albert Einstein what does it mean to us
well it's perhaps the most famous
scientific equation in all of history
boom mmm if it's so famous then why have
I never heard of it the beauty of this
equation is its simplicity E which
stands for energy equals mass times the
speed of light squared so what you're
saying is e equals MC squared yeah
exactly
but what if we were wrong what if II did
not equal MC squared well I guess that
would make it 2 times that I don't give
a
I don't know professor I mean it's a
pretty ironclad theory countless
scientists come on people
open up your minds no not that way pet I
needed to speak to someone well-versed
in Einstein's field of expertise so I
tracked down a professor on the internet
so if you could explain in the simplest
terms
Einstein's equation e equals MC squared
of course yeah I know it but when
Einstein came up with that equation with
the basic statement he was making was
that you can get energy from mass and
from mass you can get energy and what
made those equal was see the speed of
light squared so E is equal to MC
squared what if we turn this on its head
and said what if II did not equal MC
squared right I know I have trouble
carrying the one what if Einstein forgot
to do that
the main question we have is how does
general relativity tie in to quantum
mechanics which is the smaller scales
once we were able to do that we're going
to be able to tie the big structure of
the universe to the tiny anti everquest
sure oh I'm uh having a date tonight and
I was wondering if I should wear a bolo
tie well do you have a really good hat
cowboy hat to go with it I have no hats
then you shouldn't worry bowtie thank
you very much
Wow nice outfit midlife crisis Thanks
here's the thing you just don't want to
do anything weird laters where are you
going I need you to be my wingman we on
a date no that is a bad idea I need you
to give me some advice like close by
like those earpiece shows I don't want
to end up with soup all over me or
something no there she is
okay just go yeah hello I'm Professor
Susan Camberwell you must be professor
rich on Shante um who gives a right
right well um shall we get something to
eat or is that too compassionate for you
major cleanse why no it's fun
food here is very underrated don't you
think
I usually don't come here I'm a strict
vegan so I go off-campus mmm
have you ever been to Papa Dom's don't
preach yes I mean no but I mean I think
off campus is very underrated where do
you go like what local art local art Oh
have you been to UM Schwartz's gallery
they feature these art paintings
directly from vaginas be good oh I gotta
go great day god I knew this plan
wouldn't work I tried to tell him I'm
sorry I'm David Crane soup I was
confused I needed to speak to the man
himself surprisingly I found him on the
Internet in 5,000 words or less how
would you describe your special theory
of relativity
yeah equals M she's found their equals
energy M equals mass C equals the speed
of light the speed of light is 186,000
miles per second okay Einstein yeah no
really
oh okay Oh keep going so it was that
equation that gave birth to the atomic
bomb have you ever been wrong about
anything well I have to think real hard
about that one but I denied quantum
mechanics and I was wrong about that
is it possible that he doesn't equal MC
squared I rest my case
no it's not it's impossible than the
light Manila Sun and event right that
that took care of that explain please is
it's in the math so we were worried you
expect us to believe that you met with
Albert Einstein did say that his theory
could be wrong well you know humans are
wrong he said so his theories could be
wrong
he loves warcraft by the way really yeah
yeah I should look into this guy oh hi
Susan what brings you here I just came
to apologize
oh don't worry I mean I think we got off
on the wrong foot I'm sorry I had to
leave your dorm so fast I had an early
class don't worry about a baby he you
forgot your toothbrush thank you and
thanks for that dick pic no Fitz long
send it along you want to kiss or
something yeah all right
I'll see you later
wait okay that's how you do it my first
marriage I had two children uh-huh and
then like I said she wouldn't she wasn't
taking care of me
exactly so I finally my cousin if your
cousins around why not and so he got
nanny right actually I wanted to marry
try to cut him oh really yeah she was 18
I was 38
you're like the Woody Allen of science
so I've got glasses of milk for each of
you please pick one up and drink there
you go you got a little on you can what
do you think tastes like round well
that's because it is dark Cuban Rome